well the Border battle continues a
federal judge has given Texas one week
to take down that floating barrier that
you see right there in the middle of the
Rio Grande the Lone Star State isn't
alone in the crisis in the city of
Chicago as you can see that black
curtain screen right is how the fourth
busiest airport in America is Sheltering
over 400 migrants they're on the other
side of that curtain that's up from the
31 that were there in the beginning of
August here to share with what he's been
seen on the ground is our buddy Chicago
reporter William Kelly William good
morning to you good morning thank God
yeah listen so what's the deal they get
433 migrants at an airport an airport
doesn't have really good bathrooms I
don't know about showers what are they
going to eat this seems like a dumb idea
well they're already complaining about
the food uh Steve it's a it's only the
O'Hare Airport is only one of 18 migrant
shelter workers in the city of Chicago
and the last time I was at O'Hare doing
a story it was on homeless Americans
living at O'Hare well the city of
Chicago has kicked the homeless
Americans out of O'Hare to make room for
the migrants it uh you know Mayor
Johnson campaigned as the people
people's mayor sadly the people are
telling me that he's the migrants mayor
it and it certainly looks like that so
William are are the migrants on the
other side of the TSA checkpoint do they
have to go through security to get to
this location they're at I don't think
security applies to them I don't think
any any of the uh requirements that
Americans are expected to uh background
checks or uh or or you know in all in
all seriousness the city of Chicago is
not recovered from the lockdowns and the
Looting of Lightfoot now we are in the
throes of the violent crime and the
migrant crisis of Mayor Johnson this is
uh you know there are millions upon
millions of dollars being spent on this
migrant crisis nobody knows where the
money is going uh what it's being spent
on you know there was a time where
Millions upon millions of dollars would
bare minimum need to be voted upon and
uh and somehow accounted for but um you
know sadly Mayor Johnson must have taken
mayor light foots course at uh at
Harvard on media relations because he
won't answer my questions yeah well
famously would not answer your questions
so the big question is with all those
migrants there you know and given the
fact that today here in New York uh
school is starting and you got to wonder
those 433 migrants out at the airport
I'm sure there's some children there
it's not like they're going to you know
go over to Hudson News to to learn
school it is horrifying uh on every
level one of the migrant shelters in
Chicago is directly across the street
from my building on Michigan Avenue so I
look out the window and it's like a
scene from Mad Max every every single
day so it is a fail on every on on every
level and sadly the the concerns of the
people of Chicago are being completely
brushed aside William we yes just one
real quick final question uh we just
played a sound bite a little while ago
of Mayor Adams here in New York blaming
Republicans and Donald Trump for the
Border crisis in New York
who in Chicago do the people of Chicago
blame for this the mayor the last the
last Republican mayor in Chicago was
about a hundred years ago Steve I'm sure
that it's all his fault but it it really
you know it really is a fail on on on
every level and and the city and the
Pete the police are not able to babysit
the the migrants and uh arrest the
violent criminals at the same time so
the people of Chicago are suffering
today Steve and you can really tell that
William Kelly sir thank you very much
for joining us today from Chicago thank
you God bless you God bless I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis